if you're still playing the division and
waiting patiently for the next expansion
I've got some bittersweet news Ubisoft
has delayed the next to add-ons to focus
on improving the game's core experience
thanks to fan feedback the team is
tackling issues the game has had since
its March release including PvP
balancing loot drops solo player
experience and much more all of this
will be packaged in the division update
1.4 coming this fall speaking to the
delay Ubisoft stated this new schedule
will not only enable us to strengthen
the core experience before adding new
content but also continuously improve it
by allowing for more production time to
ensure the quality of future updates as
well we remain committed to delivering
the best experience possible and will
constantly be looking for your feedback
as we shape the future of the division
the division second expansion survival
is now coming sometime quote later this
year the third expansion last stand is
set for early 2017 if this schedule
changes again you'll hear about it from
GameSpot and for all the biggest news
out of Ubisoft you're already in the
right place
you